let's say a friend text you a photo of a
butterfly don't know what to say well
Google is now ready with a response we
are in real-time detecting the entities
in that picture using a sophisticated
dementia cognition algorithms so we're
not just saying butterfly we're actually
saying how nice and how beautiful it is
which is what as a user I'm most likely
going to respond this is a low a llo a
new AI powered messaging app from google
do to arrive later this summer on both
googles on Android and Apple's iOS
operating system among other things it
offers what are called Smart replies
which is a bit like what you can get
today from Google's Gmail service but
there's a key difference if you're sent
a photo a lo can analyze the photo and
suggest possible replies to that I'm not
just going to say it's a skydive in the
course of a conversation and most likely
going to respond with something like so
great Google is just one of many tech
giants from Apple to Microsoft to
Facebook now working to build a new kind
of messaging that these messaging apps
not only handle all sorts of
communications but include this new
breed of chat bot which can respond to
all sorts of requests the difference
here is that Google's chat bot
integrates with Google Plus you'll
notice as its members who I am shining
with Google is inherently conversational
so let's look at a question like how
tall is bb-8
and you'll see here not only do I get a
precise answer the suggestion chips
actually help me keep the conversation
pointy if you ask it about the Warriors
it'll give you more your scores want to
learn more about Stefan curry no problem
now I think we're the Google assistant
really becomes powerful at a low is when
you go back and bring it in and do a
group conversation Alec is suggesting we
get Italian food tonight and as you can
see one of the suggestion chips here
actually is not just a smart reply but
it's the assistant saying I can find out
more information about Italian food
tapping into the Google search engine
Calla will also pull up maps restaurant
menus and reviews you will even
integrate with third-party apps like
open table and what's really great here
is right in the group conversation a
little and assistant have helped me
complete attacks all this is designed to
happen as you're chatting with friends
and family remember this is a messaging
app you'll also find goofy stickers a
whisper shout resizing messaging feature
and yes it works with emoji
there's also an incognito mode which
adds end-to-end encryption to your chats
so no one else can read them not even
Google soon Google will also offer a
living room device that will sit on say
your coffee table and allow you to ask
questions via voice but let's not forget
Apple Amazon Facebook and Microsoft are
all working towards a similar goal
towards a digital assistant that works
well like a human assistant we'll have
to see who gets there first